[Musique]
naturellement quand j'étais petit vu que
j'étais hyper actif
j'avais besoin de canaliser mais mes
énergies donc j'ai commencé je faisais
des battles de battage de battles et je
faisais que ça tous les week-ends on
était un groupe qui s'appelait badji et
on partait tous les week-ends faire des
battles en fait
[Musique]
en fait j'ai vu un battle et je suis
tombé amoureux de cette discipline
direct j'ai eu l'énergie qui sortait ça
c'était fou et le mec qui m'a appris la
danse ils voulaient pas me prendre avant
8 ans par rapport à des problèmes de
nuque et de corps et du coup j'ai
commencé dès que j'ai pu j'ai commencé à
8 ans c'est plus une manière
d'extérioriser je pense que la danse
c'est ça aussi j'avais l'impression
d'être solide à 14 ans tellement que la
danse a marre ça m'a aidé dans mes dents
mais fondation est ouest samassa m'a
vachement changer parce que déjà le
corps ils s'adaptent ils s'adaptent à ce
que tu fais par exemple chez des bulles
audois j'ai un début de calvitie parce
que je tourne sur la tête j'ai le haut
du corps qui est super mini musclé et
j'ai des gens de tout film parce que je
suis pas force de me porter de d'être à
l'envers donc en fait je le sais hyper
intéressant ce que le choriste liste
modules complètement en fait à à ton art
à chaque fois que je me retrouve dans
une salle j'arrive à ressentir des
choses qui me dépassent moi même où je
me perds je ferme les yeux et j'arrive
vraiment à partir
et souvent c'est dans des moments où
j'ai des merdes dans la vie je sais pas
pourquoi mais c'est souvent quand quand
est chargée émotionnellement et ce qui
m'arrive souvent
et voilà les questions qu'il ya plein de
choses lourdes en moi et c'est fou
comment il se passe quelque chose de
magique à l'intérieur de mon corps où
tout d'un coup j'ai l'impression que
c'est ma manière de voir un ostéo j'ai
l'impression que tout se replacent mon
corps mes épaules mon coeur mon esprit
et tour prend forme et après avoir dansé
une heure je marche dans la rue et je me
sens bien dans mes baskets direct
j'ai cette vision des espaces j'ai envie
de tout projet envie de de gras y est
tout ce qu'il ya comme l'espace autour
de moi et j'ai pas toujours vu ça ça
m'arrive
vivre dans une pièce avec ma mère et mon
petit frère et je sais que bas cette
notion de l'espace je me suis rendu
compte à quel point elle était précieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors viens avec moi
fethi aux bleus histoire d'être raccord
je me sens bien il ya des bonnes ondes
je sens qu'on écrit ce connecter ouais
bah la maison on va se mettre en tenue
s'échauffent et se faire un petit point
sur des petits qu'à lens donner de la
force et se dire merde et après il ya là
j'ai juste eu peut éviter de faire des
blagues c'est dans des films et de la
roche posay ça la rochelle est posée
jusqu'au jusqu'aux petites embrouilles
on y est on y est on y est on y est
[Musique]
magnifique c'est la première fois que
j'écris une pièce donc donc c'est là
qu'elle est assez jeune et j'ai choisi
des dents s'est rebâti mot qui m'inspire
et qui m'inspirent en tant qu'humain
autant que quand on qu'artiste on essaye
d'avoir un truc plus que juste le taf et
mes danseurs j'ai pas envie que ça soit
juste des robots qui travaillent pour
moi et qui juste se contente de faire
les corrigent leurs tonnes j'ai envie
qu'ils proposent quelque chose aussi
on va être connectés les uns les autres
ça se tromper c'est de me fait le plus
possible et de le cacher le plus
possible de ne pas faire à et de
regarder les autres en souriant
restez dans votre truc
premier round ça parle de plusieurs
choses différentes c'est aussi une
introspection sur moi où je parle pas de
mes relations amoureuses je parle de
l'ajustement des gens qui sont mal dans
leur peau
plus j'avançais dans le game 2 dans mon
métier plus je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait des gens qui étaient qui
était hyper triste et des justes et de
comprendre pourquoi en fait ces genres
et est restée et pourquoi ils étaient à
côté de leurs pompes en fait et j'ai
ressenti que c'était parce que en fait
c'était ils s'écoutent et pas eux mêmes
et qu'ils n'étaient pas en accord avec
la personne qui sont réellement parce
que moi même je les ai vécus à des
moments je me suis perdu je me suis dit
mais léo tu t'es passat est plus vrai
que ça il faut que tu te retrouves faut
que tu te sens tu es en fait cette pièce
parle beaucoup de ça du fait de le
perdre se retrouver de se faire de se
retrouver mais ne jamais quitter
l'enfant la base la base que que tu es
en fait mieux sur tout
[Musique]
l'homme s'en libérer un an de travail un
peu plus libre qu'un seul nom commun du
tiff c'est tellement bon achement sont
allés boire de l'eau juste boire de
l'eau genre avant toute chose c'est dur
avec le soleil qui tapait là mentalement
c'était un peu chaud